[intro music]
[crash]
Good morning, John it's Friday, February 2nd
and this is the first day that I've done a video
on an even-numbered day.
I also wanted to say, "Hi," to Lauren,
who made the first Brotherhood 2.0 reply video, on YouTube.
Uh, well done.
(beep beep) Ah! Change the battery pack?
That's not okay!
Okay!
I have to do this- really quick stuff now!
And I wanted to say, "Hi," to all 300 of those people at the EPA Conference.
I'm on the way to Sarasota, Florida.
The rest of this video will be watching what I did this morning.
It's the opposite of the rest of my movie-magic videos.
Where it goes...backward in time.
You're now going forward in time at the beginning and now you're going back.
So go back! (whispers) Go back, go back, bye.
Some of my friends were telling me last night that my hair is sometimes a little bit messy on Brotherhood 2.0.
So last night...I went to bed with wet hair.
I haven't actually touched it yet so I wanna see what it looks like in its preserved state.
Kind of a...skateboard ramp going on.
And...like, a wave.
And little tufts. Tufts, like I'm a baby bird.
I think if I touched it, it wouldn't actually even do anything.
It's just gonna all stay there.
Oop, okay, much worse. Much worse than it was.
Now I look funny.
This is what my hair looks like now that I've touched it.
I don't have time to fix it, though.
I'm getting ready for my next jaunt.
I'm in Orlando now, and I'm about to be...in...Sarasota, Florida.
Which is nearby Tampa, Saint Petersburg.
As an apology to all Orlandans who were upset by my comments that Orlando sucks-
actually no one seemed upset at all-
I'm going to list a couple of reasons why Orlando doesn't suck.
One reason is that my friend Andrew has the game Guitar Hero.
Look how awesome I look.
I'm playing David Bowie's Ziggy Stardust
and I am PLAYING David Bowie's Ziggy Stardust.
I'm just slidin' up and down the neck.
Look at me.
Look at me having a good time.
Yeah!
It occurs to me that playing Guitar Hero may be another one of those things that feels cooler than it looks.
Another awesome thing about Orlando is Little Vietnam.
In Missoula, Montana, we don't really have a lot of ethnic diversity.
And it's really nice to have a part of town, here, that's a little bit different from everywhere else.
The language is a little bit different
and it's written on a sticky bun.
The religious icons are a little bit different.
(singing) The fish are a little bit different. The smells are a little bit different.
The eggs are a little bit different and the lunch meat is strange!
(no longer singing) Generally, when I go into one of these stores, I just end up buying candy.
And now I'm going to say my sign-off.
I'll see you tomorrow!
No!
I'll see you on Monday.